[Applause]
[Music]
so I would like you to think for a
minute about your most recent failure
seriously I want you to think about that
for a second and then I want you to
think about the biggest flop you've ever
had in your career or in your life now
imagine for a moment that you take that
learning those failures as stepping
stones towards your success that's the
journey I have been on for the last 30
almost 30 years and I want to take you
on today
so I'm gonna okay
I'm Brian Scudamore from 1-800 GOT JUNK
the founder and CEO when I think of the
business and the journey that I've taken
WTF an attitude a willingness to fail
has been so incredibly important if I
look at my journey it has not been in a
straight line and I bet that your
journey will not be a straight line
either
whoever said these overnight successes
take a long time was absolutely right so
let me start by taking you back for a
minute I'm not a PowerPoint guy so I
always forget how to use clickers that
is me seriously that is me four and a
half years old a self-portrait my
grandmother I'm a Canadian but I was
born in San Francisco my grandparents
had an army surplus store south of
market he used to go down every
Christmas every summer vacation and work
in the store
and taste that entrepreneurial spirit
when my grandmother passed away loved
her more than anyone on this planet when
she passed away I was about 30 and we
went through her stuff and found this
picture
and it was in a binder that said Brian's
drawings and I really remember in that
moment connecting with this illustration
and going that is me I remember drawing
it I look at that a mini uniform same
blue colors for 1-800 got junk cleaning
up trash like how could that have
happened it was like destiny who thinks
had become an adjunct man and becomes
one but I look at that picture and one
part perplexed me when I saw it if you
look on the road I drew behind me
there's a little broken heart
WTF why a broken heart did I have a bad
childhood
hell no so let me take you to 20 years
ago so what I am I 48 years old I start
this business and I'm about eight years
in I'm at a million in revenue felt
pretty good maybe not as grow as fast
growth as many of you are going through
but I was proud this truck this was
truck number two and a little point to
note you can see we ran at a red paint
there and didn't have a money for that
another spray can so finished in blue
I'm colored blind but no one else is
anyways so I said okay I've got this
business I feel like I'm not happy and I
wasn't I started to do some reflection
at that eight year point million in
revenue but I had anxiety every day I
don't know if anyone here has ever
experienced panic attacks I had them
every freaking day for ten years it was
depression panic and anxiety why did
that happen I don't know but I realized
I was a business owner I was no longer
this ad D well i'm still a DD but I was
no longer this ad D junkman who dropped
out of high school and started this
business I was a business owner but what
I wasn't anymore was an entrepreneur I
wasn't a creator I was doing a
day-to-day job and I was stuck I was
dealing with problems I didn't love the
problems and it was a challenge so I
decided to do something a little bit
differently I needed some help turn to
others so I approached the 'enter the
young entrepreneur organization
it's now shortened we all got old so
they shortened it to EO instead of ye o
they drop the Y but the entrepreneur
organization my business would not be
half of what it is today if I didn't get
that peer support but a mistake happened
when I joined EO and the mistake was
this if any of you have ever done the
same thing it's painful comparing
yourself to others looking at other
entrepreneurs seeing what mistakes
they've made I wasn't looking at their
mistakes I was looking at their
successes and I was saying you know what
I I want a 10 million dollar business I
want a hundred million dollar business I
was putting pressure on myself let's
face it I'm not in the sexiest business
in the world and so I compared myself to
others and it hurt so there I was in
this Doom loop I was going down this
downward spiral and I learned in the EO
organization if you need to solve a
problem if you want to be creative you
take a retreat so I went and took a
retreat and I feel like I'm actually
standing on the edge of my parents
summer cottage docks so I'm gonna have a
seat for a second I went to my parents
cabin alone on the water and I sat there
on the dock and I'm like Brian I didn't
really talk to myself but I thought it
and I said you know what I'm failing I'm
making mistakes I have to shift my
thinking or I'm not gonna get through
this and ever be an entrepreneur so I
took out a sheet of paper one-page
double-sided and I said okay what if I
stop thinking of the bad and the in the
challenges what if I think a pure
possibility what could that look like if
you've ever seen the movie Jerry Maguire
it was a Jerry Maguire moment I'm
feverishly writing one page double-sided
and I said things like we will be in the
top 30 metros in North America by
December 31st 2003 that was a five-year
vision I said thirty because we've been
in 30 cities bigger than where we
started in in Vancouver with there were
30 cities bigger we were gonna make this
happen we'd be the FedEx a junk removal
on-time service up front rates clean
shiny trucks friendly uniform drivers
we'd even be on The Oprah Winfrey Show a
bunch of nonsense to anyone else that
might potentially read that but to me I
went back to being an entrepreneur my
anxiety went away because I now had a
vision for the future
so I took this painted picture and I
started sharing it with others people
around me and people ended up in one of
two camps are you a supporter and a fan
of Bryan's vision do you see what I see
or are you someone who's a naysayer and
that was okay and the naysayers about
half the people said I don't believe in
what you believe I don't see what you
see and so these people left and I let
them go and together the rest of the
group we made magic happen
we got the Oprah Winfrey Show I remember
being a guest on the show we made all
the the FedEx a junk removal a bunch of
great media and we hit the top 30 cities
two weeks before December 31st 2003 it
was intact an accident we had a crystal
clear vision a future destination where
we were going now armed with this vision
of where we were going what I did not
know is how to get there
I didn't need to know I just had to
believe in the destination so what I did
is I said okay I'm going to embrace this
WTF lifestyle culture I'm gonna put
myself out there put it all on the line
to make the vision happen if I make
mistakes if I fall flat on my say my
face awesome I'm gonna learn from those
so let me share with you some of my
favorite WTF moments so this was truck
number two a couple years maybe a year
after this point I made my first WTF
mistake I had 11 employees and I
remember sitting with all the love
employees one day and I said I'm not
happy again this isn't working I don't
think I've recruited the right people
they weren't happy hard-working hands-on
hungry people that wanted to be a part
of my vision so I got rid of everybody
nine bad apples spoils the other two I
said to all 11 this isn't gonna work out
I'm sorry
some of them were very tall and big and
it was intimidating I did it all at once
to rip off the band-aid and I said I as
the leader as the founder of let you
down I might not have hired the right
people trained you give them that you
the love and the support you needed the
only thing I can see to do is start
again
the learning for me was I had five
trucks half a million in revenue I went
down to one truck one person one big
brick cell phone taking all my calls
hiring dispatching booking everything it
was a nightmare I mean it was I think it
was 3 months to rebuild it could have
been longer it was a nightmare but what
it taught me each and every one of those
3 months was that you have to make a
company all about people all you have in
any brand in any business is people make
it all about people find the right
people and treat them right and that
became my new mission for myself so
thanks for the whistle so number two my
my second big WTF moment what did they
say don't hire friends yeah I'm an
entrepreneur I don't listen to that kind
of garbage I recruited my best friend he
had built up a franchise company with
College pro painters had done some great
stuff so Cameron Harold I bring Cameron
into the business we grew it from 2
million to a hundred and six million in
six or seven years hyper growth it was
awesome but then I realized at some
point oh my gosh we're like nitro and
glycerin we are fire ready aim we have
two entrepreneurial e minded people at
the top those of you that are
entrepreneurs I talked to one person
that you might all know here and I'm not
gonna say his name but he said I'm a
shitty manager I said you're an
entrepreneur give yourself permission to
be a crappy manager but find a great
manager find someone to partner with so
I had partnered it taught at the time
with Cameron Harold realized we were
like nature and glycerin that it wasn't
gonna work and I had to end that
friendship and fire my best friend I was
the best man in his wedding a year prior
who fires their best friend now
thankfully Cameron and I are still
really good friends we see each other
off and we've supported and helped each
other in our journeys
and while it was hard in the beginning
he understood he would say to anyone
here it was the right move for both of
us it was the right move for the
business the WTF philosophy for me was
get out there put it on the line do the
right thing because when you're building
a business when our company was a
hundred million the responsibility's way
beyond me so I started to go okay now
now what how do I continue to grow this
by myself I'm not a good manager I'm now
the guy in charge I don't know if I can
do this
so I needed rigor discipline systems i
over hired I hired a fancy recruiter
they came in big box ridiculously big
bucks I then went out and searched and I
found the ex ex president of Starbucks
who wanted to move from the Seattle
location back home to to Vancouver where
she was from Lindsay who introduced me
wrote an article about this which was
titled and there's a little
anger there not with Lindsay but how I
felt in that moment it sucked
it was my biggest WTF moment of my life
when I recruited this person not the
recruiting but the 14 months later that
would follow I thought oh my gosh this
is unbelievable someone's beat this
person is loved by everyone in the
business our franchise partners loved
her and as things started to build and
grow day by day I realized my vision was
here
hers was slightly different and I don't
think she believed in an ad D crazy high
school dropout entrepreneur she needed
to for us to be successful together got
her out WTF moment of the day and I said
okay I got to start again here and what
I learned from that moment was I had
made a decision that not one person in
my company believed at the time they
believe today but they did not believe
at the time was right they didn't see
what I saw and what was happening and
where we were at so I I did this I then
get hit with a lawsuit for constructive
dismissal all sorts of bad things
started to happen and it went from
crappy to worse but I made it through
and when I look back actually as an
ingredient that I think is is part of
success that is important for all of us
to remember well for me to remember whom
I to tell you what to do I was angry
about this for a few years right it was
hard I almost bankrupted we almost
bankrupted together my company that I
built for 20 years
it was hard it was painful it caused
family issues the whole bit but I've
learned to feel grateful and I mean a
truly heartfelt sense of gratitude like
I mean that like you wouldn't believe
because I learned from it and I realized
I couldn't get to my next stepping-stone
my next awesome place in life where we
are today if it wasn't from that moment
I needed to experience I needed to fall
flat on my face by hiring the wrong
president from my company
she's gone on to be incredibly
successful leading the financial
institution in Canada they're massive
she's doing great she was the wrong
person for me so what I did is I took
out another sheet of paper and I said
okay line down the middle what do I love
to do as an entrepreneur in my company
what am i great at what do I hate to do
on the other side and what am i bad at
and yes that list was a lot longer than
the good side but what I recognized is
all these things on my bad at not good
outside that I don't like to do hiring
finances metrics I had to recruit
someone that would come into my business
to partner on that side so I sat down
and created a mini painted picture I
wrote down what does this person look
like act like who are they
attitude for winning the sales
experience that having built something
big before and just I mean I listed in
full detail this painted picture that I
started to send out to my network 75 cos
I interviewed all over Canada and the
United States was always on planes three
people in my network unrelated when I
sent out this picture three different
people had sent me one person's name
back they didn't say hey here's three or
five people I know that fit the bill
these three people all said this is only
one person I know exactly who you're
describing a nuts Eric Church so I'm
like I got to meet this Eric Church he's
got a great job he's gainfully employed
he's leading a big company but somehow
when I reached out and called and
connected he connected with the vision I
wrote for him and the vision for us to
build something great together so
grateful again for the Starbucks
experience led me to Eric
we have almost a half a billion Canadian
in revenue so like four dollars we have
we have four brands all under the o2e
brands family I have never been happier
we've got this great culture and we're
building something really really special
so when I where's the clicker so when I
look at where we are now I one of the
things that I figured out is if you're
going to have a WTF moment
WTF towards what not just towards what
vision and painted picture but towards
what drives you you are all unique
people twenty five hundred of you that I
can't see a single one of you because
the lights are so bright but all 25 of
you are unique and special and have a
purpose in life
mine I believe is making meaning not
money what really motivates you I think
that when I talk to different
entrepreneurs I hear people say I want
these toys and cars and dream trips and
freedom is fun and it's nice to have
some money but I think when someone's
motivated mostly by money it becomes
harder and harder to actually get
towards that goal so I challenge you to
think what really drives you motivates
you what makes you tick
so for us as a company it's building
something bigger and better together
those are members at our franchise
conference from four brands we love what
we do because we're building it together
and so that's what drives us in
everything we do to recruit so if I kind
of leave you with a couple of thoughts
here you know I was asked to speak and
I'm excited to share any lessons learned
along the way and I've had help from
entrepreneurs so if there's any way that
I can help any of you hey we're human
beings let's connect you can reach me I
think my Instagram is the best way at
Brian Scudamore let me see oh I'm going
the wrong way there we go
so at Brian's Scudamore if you want a
painted picture many people go out you
know you talk
two minutes about a paint painted
picture I don't really get it if you
want to see our current painted picture
it's not a public document but one I'm
happy to share with you as entrepreneurs
go to my instagram follow me send me a
little note and there'll be a link there
for you actually in the in the header of
the bio today where you can download our
painted picture copy bits and pieces
that might resonate in the template
whatever it is for you but if you don't
know where you're going any road will
take you there the second thing is I've
recently written written a book as an
EDD entrepreneur that was a really
really hard thing but now it's gone to
the publishers when it's ready if anyone
wants to hear more about the story I'll
send you a hardcover book for free again
go to that link and do whatever you need
to do okay so if I can help you contact
me I think one of the beauties about
entrepreneurship is entrepreneurs help
entrepreneurs we connect we network and
I think it's it's like magic when it
happens so as I close here and it's
humbling because I'm up here talking
about the fact that we've built this
business but many of you are going to
build something so much better bigger
the learning you will share with
entrepreneurs it's unbelievable
and as I stand here on again what
reminds me of standing at the dock I
didn't expect the stage to look like
this but it's it reminds me of that day
where that what I learned behind me
figured out this WTF mentality of how to
change my thinking to be grateful to
seize opportunities and build on them
that's pave the way for the the next 30
years
so the previous 30 years have paved my
way for the next 30 I hope all of you
see the moment and the opportunity to
create your own painted picture your own
vision for yourself your people and
possibility thank you so much for having
me and and listening to my story thank
you thank you
you